just some breaking news the shadow
transport minister sam tarry has been
removed from the uh
labor front bench uh labour party
spokesman said the labour party always
stand up for working people fighting for
better paid terms and conditions at work
this isn't about appearing on a picket
line
but members of the front bench sign up
to collective responsibility
that includes media appearances being
approved and speaking to agreed
front bench uh positions we can speak to
uh political correspondents liz bates so
uh
um sam terry removed from the front
bench liz
yes he has been and this has been a row
that has been brewing i think for
a few weeks it's fair to say within the
labour party and that's because they
they have come under some criticism some
of their mps
uh on the left of the party have chosen
to
join the picket lines with the unions
with striking workers now they've come
under fire
from the conservative party have tried
to use that to
almost preemptively blame the labour
party for some of the kind of rail chaos
that we expect we've already had and we
expect to continue
um over the summer and i think it's this
has caused a bit of a rift internally
within the labour party the leadership
at first took quite a strong line on it
and said that they really didn't want to
see their mps out on the picket line uh
they they softened that position a
little bit now sam terry uh is in
kyostama's shadow cabinet he is the
shadow transport minister and he has
been at picket line this morning at
houston doing media appearances and this
afternoon he has been sacked um we heard
actually this morning from samtari he
appeared on this program this is what he
said this isn't about me and what
happens to me this is about the 40 000
people that have decided to lose a day's
pay people who have paid not very much
money at all
that's the focus of today it's about
saying there's a red line that needs to
be drawn in the sand because the way the
government are treating workers across
britain is absolutely disgraceful
it's quite interesting the way that the
labour party have actually uh worded
their statement on this that they've
said this is that this is not about
santa appearing on the picket line this
is about
media appearances and collective
responsibility essentially saying uh
he's been speaking out freelancing uh on
his uh off his own back if you like and
he's essentially uh not uh following the
kind of discipline the lines that the
party are putting out and that's why
he's been sacked and that is presumably
because they don't want to go down this
route
of sacking anybody that is uh in
kiesdama shadow cabinet that appears on
the picket line but it will be
interesting to see as these strikes
develop over the summer and
things get even more difficult for
commuters
if this causes more internal rifts
within the labour party